foreign
foreign
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims how you
guys doing
alhamdulillah bro you looking cute man
have you eaten alone is that why you
were shaking your head so hard like you
couldn't believe it yeah bro you were um
kind of I feel like I gotta loan my gaze
bro
I'm just playing I'm just playing this
is the third Muslim for anyone that's
joined
um you know last few days new Subs like
yo two Muslims bro I just see fired and
Romney who's who's the third Muslim he's
so beautiful brother over here
[Music]
how did that we could have been so deep
with that we could have been like bro
you're the third Muslim it's the three
of us you know the two of us on screen
one person oh that's true bro
to everyone that has made it to the
Stream
exactly hair
Catherine hello hello Catherine
all right let's uh let's go into it so
Abba and preach who are they they're
YouTubers
um we I think we targeted I don't want
to say targeted bro come on we addressed
a little bit about what they said on the
stream a few days ago for anyone that
missed it let's see what happened
what this guy is right I don't know how
he is I think you showed it was like ABA
or Ada and something right yeah let's
invite him to come talk we invite you to
come talk not harshly not fight not to
come and attack you about leaving a time
whatever we invite you to come talk
about us now if you really loved Islam
and you're and you're sure that Islam is
false and stuff okay come talk to us
Insha'Allah and don't worry about life
Muslims actually never coming after you
I think that's at least he always like
you should probably worry about someone
though
a little bit more Grand scale things man
and then three days later they dropped
this video bro
so I think it's only fair that we
respond to it
um and there's uh someone commented this
crazy how the Beards get larger from
left to right almost like a Pokemon
progression bro
you guys have anything you want to say
before we go in uh someone wrote It's
pronounced
and I think it's because I mispronounced
it in the video I said Ada or Ava
because I wasn't sure
um okay okay 100 viewers in the Stream I
say we go in right now Bismillah
and uh inshallah will pause it every now
and then just to give her comments
talking about this I was talking about
his with who there's a part of me
um no answers there's a part of me that
is
a bit envious of religious people
I can get that oh yeah you know what yes
and disclaimer neither me or preach are
religious okay well we do come from
households that are semi they're fairly
religious Muslim one and yours being
Christian Baptist my mama gonna it's
gonna break my mama heart want to hear
that one my mama's heart been broken oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah but it's okay I just put
a check on the table give her that
Devil's lettuce yeah she shut the [ __ ]
yeah that green and she'd be like ah my
son is so good and then the devil's
letter is actually weed so what you just
said is
to the topic there's a part of me that
does
uh I already want to chime in bro he's
basically saying that he's he's he's
he's doing Haram things he broke his
mom's heart he left the dean but he
brings her the cash at the end of every
month
and she kind of loves it so
I mean it's I hate to be in that
situation bro and and there's a lot of
people bro there's a lot of parents too
that like they genuinely need money so
because of that it's a normal human
thing where it's kind of like you know
what I don't agree with you morally I
don't agree with you you know what
you're doing but because you're giving
me money I'm just gonna shut up and it's
a very sad compromising place to be bro
yeah and he's he's making light of a
situation that really shouldn't be made
light of you know like
if your mom's heart is really broken
like if your mom really feels some type
of way because you left the DNA she only
wants the best for you
like just just think about that in Islam
like our mother is a hotel very high
position
like there was um bro when I was getting
married the Imam was like saying about
the position of the mother and he was
saying this one guy he I think he came
to one of the scholars and he was asking
like uh
you know my mother can't walk my
mother's paralyzed or something like
that so I put her on my back and I did
the Hajj
with her on my back and I climbed up the
uh I think my arafa
is it
I don't think so basically he did the
whole Hajj and he did it several times
and then he said to the the Sheikh he's
like I I did this for my mother on my
back and I did the hush for her with her
on my back several times like have I
completed my duties
as a son to her
and he's like not even this not even a
fraction of what she did like what she
went through to bring you into this
world and to be able to nurture you into
the person that you became now
so like just just think about that like
the mother is out to such a high degree
and it's even in the Hadith where
the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam says that you know someone
asked him like oh who's the most it's
the most important person in uh in our
life right
or something like that he's he replied
uh the mother like our mother and then
he's like oh but after that he's like
your mother and then he's like after
that your mother again but then it's the
father
fourth time it's the fourth time it was
the phone yeah bro so like just just
take that in bro take that in as to how
important the mother is and here you are
making light of a situation when your
mother is just wanting the best for you
and she feels some type of way so it's
like brother you shouldn't be making
money or something like that you
shouldn't be joking around about
something like that and if you're
helping your mom out like keep that
little key bro like why why would you
Flex that
you know like why would you why would
you Flex helping your mom out like this
um sincerely like this is sincere
question
like you should want the best for your
mom like if you're helping your mom out
like that with money like don't but come
on now don't be don't be putting your
mama like that don't be exposing your
mouth
um
no I agree bro I agree because at the
end of the day the best Deeds are those
that are kept secret bro that we do for
the sake of Allah nothing else
Rami what about you before we continue
I don't really have anything to say to
be honest all right I'm the love bro
let's continue
um Envy religious people yeah but I'll
give you the first floor first what are
some of the reasons that you um he's
giving me money to the topic there's a
part of me that does
um Envy religious people yeah but I'll
give you the first floor first what are
the some of the reasons that you
understood what I said I'm curious maybe
because you know when they say ignorance
now I'm not trying to say that I'm Neo
and I'm like you know woke and
everything and stuff and I know the
truth
it's just that I'm thinking about a lot
of things that are making that don't
make sense to me and they don't have
that right and they can they have this
way this this thing that they can go to
and if they feel bad you know they feel
some kind of bad they could just Jesus
you are my joy wedding they could just
hey
[Laughter]
but that gospel
you know I started liking Kanye again
he's doing them church services
that's a thing
when you sing ugly and you sing with a
purpose okay you don't seem to be you
don't seem to be pregnant are you saying
ugly and you sing with a purpose you
understand what I'm saying
yes God you sing
like your whole life depends on it you
know what D'Angelo said well he learned
to sing in the church and what his
Pastor would say when he going up the
same what do you say he said you ain't
up there to look cute no you sing it for
the Lord you're saying it you sing it
for the Lord so sing like it you ain't
up there to look cute I said oh and I'm
like that's how I like my you know when
you make them face
and you hit them notes and you're like
yeah is it like Greens Greens potatoes
I'm like yeah that lady
that lady's a pastor she is right she
did her thing yeah and even she was
talking about food you understand there
was a purpose
because it was about it was not just
talking about food like the food I was
gonna be on the table at Thanksgiving
that was not it it was the food that was
gonna be on the table and I was blessed
by the Lord that's what it was you
understand what I'm saying singing with
a so when she sit and she hid that beat
your name it and she hid that note it
was with a purpose so there's always
that thing I understand why people go to
church yeah I understand the feelings
I've been there too and I've like that
this old camaraderie that goes into the
church he got people supporting you it's
like it's like kind of a safe space uh
even though there is no such thing as
safe space but it is a safe space for
them to get together and talk about who
whatever they got and even if you talk
about your problems and you're able to
just say oh today I had a bad day
I had a bad day I woke up one morning I
had a bad day people yes my brothers and
sisters I woke up and I felt sad but I
knew that I could have Jesus in my heart
amen and all that just said that opening
up it makes you feel good
you know how you can feel good too
therapy but that's just me okay that's
me that [ __ ] that gospel [ __ ] it is
different and I'm baptized I'm not
Catholic I'm Baptist Baptist so that's
what we did you understand so so I get I
get all that now I envy then because you
know there's always a thing there's
always someone that you can talk to
there's a feeling that there's always
someone that you can tell whether you
can believe it or not you're a Christian
there's someone that you can talk to
there's someone that you can rely on
that you have a purpose in life you
always have to wear people that do not
believe in God
have to work a little bit harder for
that to happen that's true okay and it
is noted that there are more sub
deletions in the people that do not
believe in God than people that believe
because the purpose is not there and you
know what's the world
what what are you going to live for
what's going to be your purpose what's
gonna be your thing well you don't when
you don't believe you got to find your
purpose somewhere else when you believe
there's a goal at the end of the title
there's a way there's guidelines I'm not
saying that when you don't believe you
don't got no guidelines but I feel like
you have I've been I've been in both you
have to work a little harder for that to
happen where those guidelines are
bestowed onto you when you believe what
what's your take yeah I think you
touched on it to some degree I think
as you get older you notice that
especially with the current times that
we live now that people sense a
community is pretty much non-existent in
a lot of places and so I think what
church or religion does a lot of the
times is it gives you a sense of
belonging to a group it gives you
communion with it on Sundays or Friday
prayers or you know holidays like Eid
and stuff like that you get this
opportunity to be with others and get
stuff that humans truly need but don't
always accept or admit to and yeah
there's just something super infectious
about being in this kind of environment
you know
I do want to address uh this comment
Haro that's unfortunate he's he might
still be Muslim not he's an ex-muslim
bro he's come out with it very clearly
unapologetically
um not something we heard through
someone else through him multiple videos
so it's clear bro but again
doesn't mean you can't come back
ain't that right boys
of course 100 100 and um
I wanna I wanna comment on a few of the
points they made because I actually
think those those are good points
they're essentially jealous of religious
people or sorry envious of religious
people because they have a sense of
community because they have a sense of
purpose and essentially what they're
talking about is and the grand scheme of
things is nihilism moral nihilism
and that's what a lack of God or lack of
religion will get you to
because we can't prove certain things
right there are certain things you
cannot prove that you either have to
just believe subjectively or presuppose
to be the truth unless you have God to
tell you right and I know that sounds
maybe a bit obnoxious or whatever but
take like for example
any any moral uh so anything you see as
immoral right theft or whatever I don't
want to say anything that would get the
stream monetized but let's take that
and imagine I asked you to prove theft
is wrong you'd be like well it's it's
not good to take property from people
okay well why is that not good
because you're harming someone else okay
but why do I not why shouldn't I harm
them
why is it bad to harm them can you prove
that well everybody wants to be pleased
and not harmful okay so so what if
everyone wants it why is that something
we should why should we do what everyone
wants there's no way to prove it you
keep going down the rabbit hole so what
it leads atheists to or a religious
people is moral nihilism there is no
objective morality there's no objective
good or bad there is no objective
purpose and there's no objective reason
to get together in a communal setting
but I could just sit in my office all
day and screw off and whatever that's
essentially what it leads people to and
that's I think what they're experiencing
and that's something in favor of
religion and it's it's it's funny
because I would argue from a religious
standpoint that God specifically created
us with these needs and he gave us
religion to fulfill these needs and make
us the best kind of society that we
could be that's exactly what the prophet
peace be upon him did with the Arabs
that's exactly what he did they were
tribalistic they were racist they were
doing messed up things man they were
bearing their daughters alive the
prophet saws came with belief in one God
and worship him and Obey him alone and
uh enjoying good and forbid evil and
basically the whole society flipped
ended up conquering like a huge part of
the world that ended up being like a
superpower in the world for like a
thousand years
and it was only until recently that you
know the Muslims basically really lost
any power that they had so
Yani like I I agree with what they're
saying and I I think it's a reason that
they should at least look into religion
because someone mentioned they see it as
a coping mechanism which maybe they talk
about later in the video Allah
um I only saw basically up until this
part so far
I was watching it yeah
I was gonna add to that bro yeah because
I saw that point too where it's like it
it kind of
it seems that they haven't actually
fully delved into
hey you know like before Islam like
there used to be this thing known as
like a truth Seeker
and if you actually think about anyone
who's actually looking for the truth
like they're going to
eventually come to Islam
it all comes back to Islam
and if they were actually looking for
the answer they were looking for the
truth
although they wouldn't have made this
video they wouldn't be non-religious as
they say so this just kind of shows that
um they're not actually seeking the
answers and you know what a lot of this
God knows best right maybe maybe deep
down inside they actually do one of the
answers but they haven't made the
necessary actions
to move in that direction or they just
maybe they're they're too early in the
journey
to even speak of you know yeah yeah and
actually I wanna I wanna sorry not to
point my cat in my hand on the camera
but to jump on that point I I actually
and this is not this is not me to like
trying to get a one-liner or a one-up on
them I actually just generally think
about what I'm saying here and if if
Avon preach if you guys are watching
genuinely just think about this I think
you guys if you believe that religion is
a coping mechanism I think you saying
that is a coping mechanism and the
reason I say this because as Muslims we
will provide evidence for why we believe
what we believe we will provide evidence
that Islam is the truth but you as
someone who's a religious would have to
bring evidence against basically every
religion or at least the major religions
that exist and disprove all of them and
then say no religion is correct it's a
coping mechanism whatever whatever so
you guys saying that is kind of and this
is not a disrespect it's normal like
people do this kind of in your position
it's almost a cop out so you don't have
to deal with religious arguments so you
don't have to deal with religion as a
whole you don't have to justify your
views you just say well it's just a
coping mechanism because when people
believe in God they feel happy in their
heart and without God they feel sad I
mean think about that people feel
happier in their heart when they think
of God
someone who's not physical someone who's
not here physically with us we can't see
we can only see the result of it's only
natural that God created us with this
capacity for a belief of him and our
heart if you think about how ideas are
formed there you see a laptop and you
see a wall and then you think like of a
laptop screen the size of a wall you
know that's how ideas are formed there's
nothing comparable to God God is the
ultimate kind of idea if you think about
it you have to take all the
like Immaculate traits and put them into
one being
and the fact that we all have this
belief as a child is not something that
our like we have this insane thinking
pattern as kids it's just something that
we were born with which means that God
created us like that so I think it's
kind of a coping mechanism for you guys
to say that Islam or religion is coping
mechanism for religious people what do
you guys think does that make sense yeah
bro I agree I just wanted to say around
me what you meant was God is like the
most unfathomable conceptual thing to
like visualize you know not like an idea
because I know a lot of people can be
like oh harami said God's an idea you
know
Elon Musk and I've seen a lot of
channels bro they go around saying that
God is an idea bro even Andrew tabro he
said God is an idea as an idea can be
powerful too and I was like no bro God
is a literal like actual entity you know
what I mean
yeah yeah
I think people might be able they might
misconstrue the term ideas I'm glad he
cleared it up idea just meaning
something you can think of
I know you have anything before we
continue
all right Bismillah
hear somebody talk about you know to
have patience because life is life is
full of suffering it doesn't matter what
religion what faith you go through life
is full of suffering being losing people
around you difficult stuff at work
heartbreak all these things and not
having a support system it makes that
suffering even more compounded and so I
have rituals that I engage in all right
I don't mean sacrifice a bit but I mean
like maybe it's specific events I go to
every Thursday or Friday this dance for
you maybe it's CrossFit on Sundays and
you get it with your group people having
these forms of like rep repetition where
you guys go through the same habits with
the same type of people like that
ABBA is the one on the right or ABA and
then preaches the one on the left
yeah this is actually a good spot to
actually pause it because he's he's
mentioning this thing and I can see
where he's about to go but these things
these like religious things that you
might be doing or let's say you want to
CrossFit
um every single week or let's say you're
doing martial arts like every single day
or multiple times a week or you're
playing music and you're learning
instruments or or your purposes like
this business or something like that
listen these things are temporary these
things are of this world these things
will give you a feeling that's a very
temporary feeling and that will pass
very quickly like when when you
when you submit yourself
and you are praying and you're
constantly seeking Allah and you're
constantly trying to humble yourself and
bring yourself down to that that place
of uh
basically submission to the Creator like
that gives you ease that gives you peace
that gives you something that's like you
know what
is not temporary it continues because
even during the hard times the ease is
still there
think about that when when you have this
like I don't care about like you could
be doing martial arts or you could have
this like CrossFit thing that you're
doing all the time and it's like a
ritual bro like you will be going
through a hard time in your life and
yeah that might help you through like
you know it might give you endorphins
you might feel good
but it's only like a very brief period
of time in your day
you know and then the rest of the time
you just like in this mental chaos like
dealing with the stuff that's going on
whereas when you are submitting to the
Creator
and you're constantly seeking to create
you're praying every single day and
you're always trying to have that taqwa
you're always trying to have the guy
consciousness
like it doesn't matter if you're going
through that hard time because you
understand that that hard time is just a
test you understand the reason for
everything that's happening
so I mean I I get where he's coming from
but at the same time like
I don't know maybe I'm speaking a little
too far here so I'm just gonna let them
I'm gonna let them speak first bro
after this pandemic can no longer
no longer how much people suffered from
not being able to do those things
unbelievable for me was like such a big
deal why I look a lot better now and
feel a lot better is because I'm out
there and I'm actually able to do [ __ ]
because I wasn't able to for a long time
so
I say all this to say that religious
people just from a community standpoint
have so much but then like preach said
it gives you a set of guidelines it
gives you your moral compass it tells
you like these are the rights these are
the wrongs instead of you having to
figure out a lot of it for yourself all
the time or have something to deal with
that and I think a lot of people need
you know
they need that framework you know what
I'm saying and so from the outside
looking in when I see folks who are so
lost and have none of that you can go
through and try to figure out yourself
but that's a one it can be very lonely
and two very difficult oh yeah very
difficult and so I think there's a part
of me that understands the need for
religion even though I'm not a Believer
or not I don't think that can change I
respect it and I appreciate it from afar
and I think yeah that's something that's
come with eight before I just I used to
think of it as a nuisance because it was
something that people kept trying to
impose on me oh yeah but now that they
no longer have that ability and I'm a
grown man I can look at it from afar and
appreciate it for what it is rather than
the thing that's trying to pull me in
all the time well you know this I was
pissed off about religion
uh bring it up a couple notches livid
okay yeah live it about about our
religion and stuff like that and you
know through the years you know you come
you calm down you listen you know you
know you just have to work things out
with what hurts you and what hurt your
community and what hurt your people and
understand where it comes from I was
pissed off yeah like
you would talk about you would talk
about religion to me
Christianity to me and my whole demeanor
would change like I was in a fight mode
he saw that a couple of times I
was I was heated you understand and I
was I was
King preached the petty
King preached the petty in full effect I
was ready to take you down and all your
arguments it was easy to invalidate them
real quick now it's not even about that
it's not about that but I was pissed
pissed yeah especially when someone's
trying to Embark me in that [ __ ] that's
cause you ain't got Jesus in your life
oh I got one for you you got a problem
let God handle it oh my God that used to
trigger the F and not up to recently oh
yeah we got a video I thought the most
viral video yes it's him getting
triggered by God yes when when the
wedding thing and when let God let God
what he said let God I need a prenup no
no no let God handle it I I you could
just go you could go back to that video
actually the preacher steps up he's like
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
he say now now hold on don't now I know
you love this girl
don't make a drastic decision I think
you should just let God handle it shut
that [ __ ] off
and you could just see my eyes right
there when he said that oh
hell nah yeah that was up to recently
and as he was doing that all I was
thinking
here we go Never Enough highest viewed
video yo you shoot that video went up it
beat the first one that we posted yeah
yeah imagine that but yeah but like yeah
that [ __ ] used to trigger you yeah
it's understandable like it doesn't
trigger me but I I got a little yeah no
no I could breathe yes knock a breathe
bro
[Music]
I think it's fine I get that bro I get
that as a born Muslim too bro I get that
because a lot of people are doing too
much bro and it can put you off and this
is the reality of a lot of Muslim
Christian families bro I used to know
this Christian guy bro he's like bro if
I if I said anything bro I would have
got kicked out in the streets bro and we
were like five
I was like subhanallah that's crazy
yeah there's there's definitely a few
notes to uh to unpack there so firstly
um I wanna let me go kind of a reverse
order so about that that brother someone
just commented saying that
uh here
by the way that dude uh they just showed
with Steph uh Stephen Jackson Stephen
Jackson uh he converts his son last year
I've seen the brother a few times
um I mean from a religious perspective
in fact actually forget from an Islamic
perspective they mentioned something
about a prenup or whatever
Islam has guidelines for what to do as a
Muslim right when you you know marry
your wife give her a gift if you divorce
do yourself to take care of her you know
taking care of your kids Islam covers
all of that stuff morally
so topic of Premium up not a printable
Islam covers all that that's not don't
worry about that and I want to summarize
this whole discussion with something
that Prophet saws he said
he said a man came to him he's like do I
do I tie my camel up so it doesn't you
know run away or leave or wander or
should I just leave it and Trust on
Allah he saw the two as a contradiction
the prophet peace upon him he said tie
your camel and Trust in Allah boom right
there do what you think is best right
seek advice to those around you go to
the those who know as the Quran says if
you don't know go to those who know and
do what you think is best and just Allah
trust God that whatever you do is is
just best
and we'll have yield the best outcome
that's what we believe as Muslims I
don't think you would contend with that
if somebody believes in religion and
also I want to touch on the point you
mentioned fire because you're absolutely
right A lot of people that grow up in
families where religion is like you know
just smacked on their head you know in a
very painful way so they associate
religion with such horrible
um you know such horrible thoughts and
feelings and and and you know all these
things that just it pushes people away
and that's not something that religion
should do to a person especially Islam
you know Islam we know how beautiful it
is so to have it slapped on the the
foreheads of so many kids is so well
that's so saddening to see
um
that's why I see a lot of men and women
brothers and sisters that are like
coming back to religion later in their
life when they finally had that space to
like come into it of their own accord
and then it's legit it's like genuine
it's authentic it's no longer like oh if
I don't do this I'm gonna get my thing
beat you know if I don't do this I'm out
on the streets if I don't do this my
mom's not gonna speak to me anymore you
know what I mean
yeah yeah and it's sad because a lot of
the time it comes from whatever culture
the people are dealing with or like just
the harshness of the parents and it's
not actually Islamic you know
islamically
well it's it's all about uh knowledge
and it's all about the Quran
like if someone has even like a um you
know a bit of skepticism or like a
question about something a lot of the
time in Christianity they'll kind of
push you aside islamically what we're
supposed to do is is answer their
question go to a scholar ask inshallah
and that's why we started this channel
right to to encourage the people
basically to look into Islam and to
answer these questions for them we got a
lot of questions about Free Will and and
determinism and all this stuff and it's
none of it's actually you know a
contradiction or once you hear the
answer it's like wow you know that's
unbelievable but you just have to kind
of break out of that shell and and
really engage with these people engage
with the Muslims and you'll see you know
what we have to offer why people like
Andrew accept Islam yes I'm going to
fill that in there
I'm good luck
but before I was going every time I was
going I feel you I get you I'll say this
I think now we're at a point where
people have so many options they can
choose to do whatever they want to do
and people are embellishing a lot of
those things they're [ __ ] left right
and Center they're doing all kinds of
substances or doing all these things and
we allow people a lot of freedoms but
what comes with a lot of freedoms
oftentimes especially if people
embellish too much is chaos comes into
your life all of a sudden you have a
harder time meeting deadlines you're
engaging all kinds of frivolous Behavior
that's not good for you and I think what
religion brings for a lot of people is a
bit of order every Sunday
ritualistically You're supposed to show
up here or if you have an issue you can
come to somebody until five it gives you
that sense of consistency that I think a
lot of people need in their lives to
feel really well I have friends who are
dealing with antidepressants and stuff
like that and I'm not saying they find
God they felt better what I'm trying to
say is just from them getting a schedule
and an order in their life getting a job
and working nine to five every single
day they started to feel exponentially
better and that's actually one of the
top things that like shrinks will tell
people when they're dealing with
depression of times it's like get a
schedule just pick three things in the
day and get those things done and see
how we feel after that and just bring
some order what I think religion does a
great job of is it oftentimes introduces
order into your life it gives you these
guidelines where it says don't do too
much of this don't too much of B don't
do too much to see it blah blah blah
blah blah or come every Sunday do these
things and that kind of order is very
comforting
um and I also think as people get older
they need that because they retire from
their jobs they have all this free time
their kids don't come to see them as
often they're community members friends
family move away or they die as you get
older that need for that kind of ordered
consistency and something to invest your
time in becomes much more apparent you
know because someone said this to me
it's like his mom turned 70 and she's
thinking about retirement and then you
know she doesn't know what she can do at
retirement so he's like oh you should
pick up a new hobby or whatever she's
like I'm 70.
like that's probably not and most old
people are not going to go and like pick
up a Guitar all of a sudden or you know
start a botany plan or whatever most of
them got their routinely like that kind
of stuff so she started investing
herself heavily to God you don't even
know her husband passed away and you see
like there's a beauty in that there's a
community that's going to take care of
you exactly and then when you're
familiar with and you've invested in for
40 50 years yeah right you're gonna have
people calling you up
how are you doing today absolutely
there's people calling you when you
ain't got nobody you know people are
gonna call you people are going to take
care of you people want to look out for
you that's how that's what you need yeah
sometimes that's what you need yeah
think about this and this really [ __ ]
me up when he said it he said
my mom been going to church
since she was her little baby she's 71.
every Sunday think of one thing that
you've done every Sunday that's a social
activity
I want you the viewer tell me one thing
that you've done every single week since
you were a baby that's socially involved
with other people and communicating
not all I work out every Sunday not that
I talk about something that you've done
real religiously
right think about there's something
really like impressive and beautiful in
that in and of itself
um and so yeah it's like that yeah I got
one like like that yeah no matter where
she at she going she's in Florida she's
in New York because y'all should go to
church good that was a church good that
that kind of order and if she doesn't go
to church you must believe that within
between that time and that time you
cannot go in a room because she praying
yeah she praying she's doing prayers she
prays for everybody
and I even used to that's how pissed off
I was and when people would come up to
you would come up to me and be like oh I
prayed for you I'd be like nah I don't
believe in that [ __ ] so don't
now I'm not as Petty and I understand
that the only thing that person is doing
whenever they they say I've been praying
for you is they wish you well
just accept it it's not your religion
it's not your thing okay the the
intention behind that is that that
person is wishing me well that's it I'm
proud of your growth thanks
congratulations thanks look at you yeah
but if Church comes to me bro I'm just
kidding listen any time you get upset
you deal with message let God handle it
it's okay [ __ ] don't push it don't push
it don't [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
a religious video is coming
actually yeah there's a lot of people
that will be asking like yo why why were
you so pissed off we'll we'll handle
that in another video nothing I mean
that could be a part too we can talk to
this video we could definitely do that
why you laugh if you want to talk about
it me I mean mine's boring
I like [ __ ] and I'm not good at being a
hypocrite
funny it wasn't alcohol wasn't it I like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] I knew I was gonna [ __ ] left or
right if we have to go to Friday prayers
and be like God and I knew that night I
was going I couldn't do that Mia I can't
one thing I can't do is be a blade
neighbor I just can't you try you're
trying to pray I try you try to pray but
all the time you're praying you're
looking at the watch to see whenever
you're going with us on when I see your
mom and then I also seen him at the club
sitting like I I I can't beat me I'm
just hard I just can't beat me that's
all so I knew who I was and I knew where
I was about now my old years maybe maybe
you never know but I I don't see myself
but why I left I like yeah I mean it is
what is it so that's all anything else
you want to say
that's both of us
oh no please bro please as a Reaver bro
and Rami and myself bro just as men bro
who doesn't like women
What man does not like women
unless you're a bati boy but aside from
all that like bro it's okay it's okay to
like women bro
come on man I want to know your thoughts
because like this is what I was thinking
the entire time but I wanted to let them
off like finish talking because I wanted
to like you know formulate my my
conclusion here but it seems like the
conclusion was on the money like right
from the rip when it was coming and it's
the these these dudes bro they're just
following enough they're following their
desires
and your desires and
they're not going to get you nothing
they're not going to get you nothing
like which one was that one that said
that he likes he likes women a lot was
that other Beach
bro
let me ask you something bro
after each time that you got yourself
some cheeks
the feeling that you felt after that
like how long did that last before you
wanted it again
like the contentment that you got up
from that like how long did that last
before you had to go and seek it again
like can you honestly say that
clapping cheeks was uh
your purpose come on like no no no no no
no a lot of guys will say oh no like as
men you know we're human or biological
purposes to clap cheeks no listen listen
can you actually say
that this this actually brings peace to
your life this you know it feels so good
that you you're willing to just give up
everything and everything for some
cheaps like that's that's sad bro
because that's basically saying like
like your worship
you worship cheeks
like that I'm sorry but like I'm not I'm
not trying to I'm not trying to claim
anything on you I'm trying to say that
you're weak as a man but any man that
worships a woman or worships cheeks
that's weak bro
that's weak
so my conclusion with all this man is
like
y'all should really
you know spend some time with yourselves
and
and disconnect from everything and
disconnect from cheeks and this guy from
the social media and all this stuff
and uh then start seeing what really
comes to you because
it's only when you disconnect that you
can start to see things clearly
yeah
subhanallah
um
I want to comment on um I think this is
speaking to a greater volume with what
basically essentially he as an
individual
I would never really believed if I'm
being honest someone who actually at any
point is like believed in Islam is not
going to leave for sin because you can
sin and still be a Muslim he said I
wasn't good at being a hypocrite if
you're a Muslim then you stop sinning
you don't stop practicing Islam you
don't you don't leave Islam basically
what he's saying is that I was I was
born into a liberal secular society and
everyone around me is doing this this
and that but my family taught me you
know this this and that and I chose one
side over the other basically that's
essentially what happened
and you know it happens to a lot of
people you know such is life I'm not
gonna you know come at the brother for
that
but now you you need to you must take a
look back and see that this was not an
intellectual where's my head an
intellectual decision
this is not something that you sat and
you pondered about and said you can't
you look at the evidence it came to the
conclusion that I should just leave my
religion and go hop into course with
women and let's be honest listen if you
really or anyone really practice Islam
you would get married
I don't care how young you are get
married I've been bro I was trying to
get married since I was 18. a few years
later I'm married now
everyone every man likes a woman
alhamdulillah even the prophet peace
upon him he said that the world is
temporary desire
but the best of that temporary desire is
a Pious wife
bro get married come on man
who what would you who would you rather
be without you know random women who you
have no connection with no shared
beliefs or values with or maybe a few
or a woman who you and her are both
willing to dedicate your life to Allah
dedicate your life to the one who
created you and bring children to the
world raise them better then hopefully
you know your parents raised you when it
comes to religion teaching the right way
and have them be leaders for the Muslims
be leaders for the people like imagine
this the universe existed for a long
time and from that the Earth came to
existence in our galaxy for a long time
right and for for all the years our
earth existed you know Allah or for lack
of a better term I'll just say humans
you know came to earth once upon a time
I'll leave the religious Adam and Eve
out of it right now but you know our
creator put us on the Earth
and then all these years later all these
children later all these people later
little baby Ava and preacher born to the
world
now from all this Allah created little
baby a band priests coming to the world
and a but he goes to the Masjid he's
taught Islam he's taught this in that
and he relieves his creator he leaves
his religion
to be able to have intercourse with with
women
but just think about that
this out of everything that Allah has
created
including you and me
not just you there's people out there
they're willing to abandon their creator
abandon the Creator abandon the way of
life abandon all those benefits of being
at least religious that you you guys
mentioned
to have intercourse with women and
that's funny I gave up I gave this last
thing I'll say inshallah on this topic I
gave a talk on
red pill and Islam
and one of the main fundamental points I
made was that red pill its whole
objective is to get women and that's why
it fails
because the entire objective the point
the the illah as you mentioned Angel the
god that they worship is is women
if you're working out looking good
working hard making money boosting your
confidence to get women
and guess what you wish you worship
women the attention from women the
intercourse with women that's your
entire purpose in life if that's not
depressing I don't know what the heck is
to be completely honest that is sad and
that's not an attack on you but everyone
every guy is doing this nowadays but
we're trying to call them away from that
you can have the Intercourse just do it
in a way that is beneficial for you for
for the woman for the community get
married and then you can say oh marriage
is a scam marriage is not a scam unless
you marry someone you should not have
married and then I'll say it's kind of
your fault my man and I would say the
same to the woman in some cases as well
but regardless
just
come have a discussion with us I'm going
to say this and then come have a
discussion with us let's talk you know
uh I understand you very well I know the
brothers do as well we all live in the
west we know what life is like we're man
we like women as well come on we're
literally from Canada too bro yeah bro I
saw that and I'm like look let's
Insha'Allah let's fly out at least you
and me let's fly out and let's go meet
them and grab them calm down bro listen
it I'll go and preach if you guys made
it this far we just want to chop it up
even if even if you don't want to record
it even if it wants to be like an
off-camera thing we just want to talk
about it Western mirrors that's the
thing we're Western marriage or is more
about a wedding than a marriage you know
what I mean I've seen so many red pill
horror stories about people being like
oh you got to spend this much on a ring
then this grandioso type of like you
know proposal
you got these women that are like oh you
know I didn't have my camera go down our
knees again let me take my camera let me
do it again you know it's so cringe bro
and it's like they're putting so much
emphasis on one day than an actual Union
bro
where at the end of the day you got two
people they don't feel they don't feel
God they're just gonna live by there
enough their desires of course bro of
course I'd be traumatized too if that's
all that there was you know but at the
end of the day in Islam marriage is
something so much more bro
like
I just want to read this comment out
because there's an eye from the Quran
I'm sorry I thought I forgot about it
Allah he says in the Quran have you seen
the one who has taken his God as his own
vain desire or he's taken his own
desires as his God
would you then be a basically a disposer
of his Affairs or Watcher over him you
know ayani are you going to watch over
the person are you going to take care of
the person
you know of basically the person who
takes their own desires them wanting to
have intercourse and fill their bellies
and all that and all that stuff that
person they're making that their God are
you gonna basically even give any
attention to this person yeah their
whole life revolves around about
basically around what they feel
what kind of instability is that your
whole life is not based on anything
rational anything solid not based on the
truth which is based on I feel this let
me do that
come on man
no there's a super [ __ ] that I wanted to
go through inshallah oh no I don't know
if you're still there from scattered
pieces podcast saying ABBA is still a
genuine dude by the way thank you for
the Super Chat he left Islam because he
misunderstands what practicing or
religion means but still a good dude
Miller got him yeah bro see I've seen
videos about like Mufti menk and
shaykhutman and addressing this topic a
lot even no man Ali Khan bro about or if
I feel it in my heart why do I still
gotta pray if I feel this why do I still
have to do that you know what I mean and
again that's that's that's a lot that's
that's a loaded question bro we can talk
about that another stream but it's a
very common thing unfortunately people
are leaving the team because of that
because over here in the west it's just
believe and that's it it's a very
Christian type of thing too in modern
Christianity just you believe and that's
it there's no practicing you got to do
you know what I mean yeah faith in Jesus
as they were saying yeah
sorry
no I think the last thing that I want to
say was like tying it all together like
Abba preach if y'all are watching this
listen like if we came off harsh forgive
us it's not our intention we just want
to outline a lot of things you know and
again we we love to talk with y'all
doesn't even have to be on camera or
anything like that it could be just you
know off camera in person so if y'all if
y'all get this by some chance
um
one of the other I don't know inshallah
five all right and with that being said